إما أن تستخدمه بنيران مضادة للطائرات
محكمة رشاش عيار 12.7
طلقة 2700 متر
[موسيقى]
مع وطننا الشاسع
الذخيرة المحملة والدبابات الأوزبكية
هو 3 وتوهج
يؤدي تحية عسكرية
رفع أو إلقاء نظرة فاحصة على نفسه
الوقت الذي يندفع فيه الفريق الروسي
أين نحن لكننا سنعود بعد قليل
حتى نداء افازبك من الدرجة الثانية
الطاقم الأول لأوزبكستان و
على الجهة اليسرى أنا على 4 مسار واحد
خزان اللون الأحمر أول مجلس الوزراء كيبا
روسية الصنع
الجانب يوفر لجميع أطقم في
الحجم الكامل لخزانات t-72 صفحة
قدمت بأمر من رئيس القضاة
تستخدم منافسة الدبابات دبابتك
نوع 96 ب متشابهة في التقنية
خصائص الآلات المكنية T-72b 30 قليلا
تبدأ المساعدة قياس الروسية
الاتحادات أولاً تحافظ على الأصدقاء
دعم فريقنا ، حسنًا ، ليس فقط
يرفع الراية البيضاء وإذا كان كذلك
الانتهاك ثم عندما رفع الحكم
العلم الاحمر وفي هذه الحالة يكون
ببساطة
ربما كذلك عند التبرع الأول
عوائق تظهر في الأداء مثيرة للجدل
خذ وقتك
لنا له أ
95 سنة من الميلاد مواطن
تمر الحافة الغالية للسيدة بشكل صحيح
من الخدمة حسب الجنسية هم يدخنون معنا
يتصاعد خزان متعدد الجنسيات للغاية
بالقرب من أصدقاء جاهزية قائد الدبابة
لا تنسى ذلك بالفعل من الماضي
في العام الأول والسادس عشر من آب (أغسطس) وهذا ليس كذلك
الرحلة ليست من أصدقاء الأوزبك
الرياضة والأوقات الجيدة حيث يؤدي
فحص التحكم القياسي للآلة
قضاء دقيقة واحدة على هذا
الآن نرى الفتيل عن كثب
الآن سيحتاج فيكتور عادي من الرقائق
تو أصدقائه الشباب في العشرينات من عمري